To develop a better approach
to the parameter learning problem,
we need to develop a new version
of the Viterbi algorithm.
As we discussed, the Viterbi algorithm
gives a yes or no hard answer
to the question "Was the HMM in state k at
time i given that it emitted the string x?"
We now want to give a soft
answer to this approach.
And to give this soft answer,
we need to define the notion
of Pr(pi_i = k,x),
which is the unconditional
probability that the hidden path will
pass through state k at time i and emit x.
For example, this question is translating
the following question for the crooked casino:
What is the probability that
the dealer was using the Fair coin
at the 5th flip given that
it emitted a given string?
So, after we define the notion
of Pr(pi_i = k,x),
we notice that this is
simply the total probability
of all paths passing through
the node corresponding
to state k in the i'th column
of the Viterbi graph.
And note that this
probability can be computed
as simply path sum through
all possible paths
pi such that Pr(pi_i = k,x) = 1.
Also, note that the sum of
Pr(pi_i = k,x)
through all possible
emitted symbols k and
all possible paths x is equal to 1.
We now introduce a different probability:
Pr(pi_i = k | x),
which is the conditional probability
that the HMM was in state k
at time i given that it emitted string x.
And in the case of the crooked casino,
it corresponds to the following question:
What is the probability that
the dealer was using the fair coin
at the fifth flip given that
it emitted a given string?
To compute the probability
that Pr(pi_i = k | x),
we notice that this probability is simply
the fraction of the product weights
of paths visiting node k over the weight
of all paths in the Viterbi graph.
Or, in other words, Pr(pi_i = k | x)
is simply the ratio of Pr(pi_i = k,x)
over Pr(x).
And therefore,
to find out what is Pr(pi_i = k | x),
we need to solve the
following soft decoding problem:
Find the probability that an HMM
was in a particular state
at a particular moment given its output.
To solve the soft decoding problem,
we first need to compute
the probability Pr(pi_i = k,x),
which is the total product weight of
all paths through the Viterbi graph for
x that pass through the highlighted
node in the graph below.
For each such path, we can note
that it is formed by a blue subpath
from the source to
the highlighted node and
by the red subpath from
the highlighted node to the sink.
And therefore, Pr(pi_i = k,x)
is equal to the sum of product
weights of the blue paths multiplied
by the sum of the product
weights of the red paths.
The first part of this equation,
sum of product weight of blue paths,
is simply the expression forward_(k,i)
that we already know how to compute.
But what is the red path of this equation?
Well, note that the red
path of this equation can
be computed if we simply will have
HMM Viterbi graph with all edges reversed.
And we will denote the product
weight of this path as backward_(k,i).
And, of course, computing backward_(k,i)
will be very similar to
computing forward_(k,i).
Therefore, since the reverse
edge connecting node (l,i+1)
to node (k,i) in the reversed
graph has weight(k,l,i),
we have a recurrence:
backward_(k,i) = sum through
all states l of
backward_(l,i+1) * weight(k,l,i).
And therefore,
combining the forward-backward
algorithm with the solution of
the Outcome Likelihood Problem,
we have
Pr(pi_i = k | x) = Pr(pi_i = k,x)/Pr(x),
which is simply
forward_(k,i) * backward_(k,i) / forward(sink).
We now know how to compute
each element in this formula.
Now, after we computed
the values forward_(k,i) and
backward_(k,i), let's ask
a slightly different question:
What is the conditional
probability that p_i = l,
p_(i+1) = k given that
the emitted string is x, or
in other words,
what is the probability that
the HMM passes through an
edge in the Viterbi graph?
And, of course, this probability is
equal to the sum of weights of all blue
subpaths in this graph, multiplied
by the weight of the black edge, and
multiplied by the sum of
the weights of all red subpaths.
And as a result,
this expression is given by
forward_(l,i) * weight(l,k,i),
multiplied by the expression
backward_(k,i+1), divided by forward(sink).